there are some stars who have showed up
on screen for just a handful of minutes
yet still managed to snag a king's most
prestigious prize often these are
supporting actors who steal the
spotlights in a few seconds but at least
one leading man when his Best Actor
Award for barely any scenes at all some
popular films stand the test of time
while others fade into obscurity
sadly shampoo falls into the latter
category
the 1975 satire tells a story of a
hairdresser played by Warren Beatty
whose juggling multiple women were
trying to open his own salon the movie
was a major hit at the time raking in
nearly 50 million dollars of the box
office it also impressed the members of
the Academy has it nabbed four Oscar
nominations however the only one to go
home of the gold was Lee grant an
actress who was on screen for just
around 18 minutes grant won the Oscar
for playing Felicia a lonely housewife
who's trying to keep her adulteress
husband's attention while conducting her
own affair with bait a Felicia is whiny
wealthy well-dressed and simultaneously
lustful and lonely even though she's
only onscreen for about 17 percent of
the film it was enough to impress the
Academy
this was Grant's third shot Oscar gold
after getting nominations for detective
story and the landlord and she finally
won the prize at nights sadly despite
her award-winning performance as scene
Shampoo has been scrubbed clean out of
the pop-culture consciousness The
Silence of the Lambs isn't your typical
award-winning film but it shattered all
Oscar expectations by becoming the first
proper horror movie to win the Best
Picture Oscar it was released in
February 1991 and 13 months later it's
somehow crushed all the more award from
the film's released during Oscar season
most importantly is one of only three
films that have won the big five Oscars
Best Picture Best Director Best
Screenplay Best Actress and Best Actor
craziest tale the best actor award went
to a man who was in the film for mere 16
minutes but every second he's on screen
is absolutely electric Anthony Hopkins
beat the likes of Robert De Niro and
Robin Williams to win the Oscar for his
turn is a sophisticated psychopath
Hannibal Lecter years later people still
talk about his performance and quote
some of his most iconic lines a census
taker once tied
me I ate his liver with some fava beans
and a nice Chianti from the moment he
appears on screen
Hopkins radiates pure evil while he
rarely raises his voice he commands
every scene he's in and with his own
blinking eyes and perfect posture he
totally a nerves audiences sure Hopkins
only shows up for 14% of the film but
every death rattling bone-chilling
moments is worth its weight in Oscar
gold that was good pity about poor
Catherine though
after earning a Best Actress nomination
for Rachel getting married and Hathaway
got a second shot at Oscar gold with
Leigh miserab an epic musical set in
19th century France Hathaway shows up
for a mere 15 minutes in a movie that
runs nearly three hours long the Walsh
only appears in 9% of the film she won
the Oscar for Best Supporting Actress
Hathaway threw herself into the park
completely losing a shocking 25 pounds
and cutting all the hair off she even
went so far as to study prostitution and
hearing the sad stories of modern-day
sex workers took a major toll then
there's a performance itself whenever
Hathaway opens her mouth she's singing
at the top of her lungs and on top of
hitting all those crazy notes
she's also acting a hotel she's
desperate and lost in trying to survive
she's angry and hyperventilating and
falling apart
once again she's doing all this while
singing and her rendition of I dream
that dream is absolutely devastating in
short she definitely deserved that award
for breaking our hearts in just 15 short
minutes in the 80s and early 90s Kim
Basinger found frequent work in films
like never say never again the natural
and Tim Burton's Batman but in 1995 she
took a break from acting for a couple of
years until director Curtis Hanson
tracked her down Hanson was adapting
James Ellroy Snee oh no our novel LA
Confidential and he thought Basinger
would be perfect for the part of Lynn
Bracken a sex worker with a heart of
gold who also looks a lot like Hollywood
legend Veronica Lake originally Basinger
wasn't interested in the parts as she
was sick of playing characters defined
by their sex appeal the hunson convinced
her to take the role and Basinger made
Lynn Bracken more than just a blonde
she'll even though Bazin go is only in
the film for 15 minutes she makes the
most of a limited time sharing intimate
moments with Russell Crowe and telling
off Guy Pearce with a powerful monologue
I see by because he doesn't know how to
disguise three years
I see but for all the ways he's
different from you it was a standout
performance I caught the attention of
the Academy and then the starring Oscar
for Best Supporting Actress during the
2000s Woody Allen kept himself busy
directing at least one movie every year
almost all of those films have been
completely forgotten by time Vicky
Cristina Barcelona has pretty much
suffered the same fate as a rest of
Alan's films from that era but there is
one little detail that saved the movie
from total obscurity
it features an oscar-winning performance
from Penelope Cruz in fact two crews won
a truckload of awards for attorneys
Maria Elena the fiery and suicidal
ex-wife of a womanizing artist she only
shows up for 15 minutes but she crushes
it in every single one of her scenes
whether she's defiantly speaking Spanish
while they trying to shoot Javier Bardem
or making out with Scarlett Johansson
Cruz is a star of the show even though
she was up against some major
competition from the likes of Amy Adams
and Viola Davis it should come as no
surprise that Penelope Cruz to victory
thanks to those stunning moments Alan
Arkin is one of those actors who should
have won an Oscar long before he finally
dead the man was nominated twice and he
had plenty of other powerful
performances in other films as well
thankfully Arkin got his well-deserved
trophy at the 79th Academy Awards for
his performance and Little Miss Sunshine
in a movie filled with amazing actors
Arkin stands out as a larger-than-life
Edwin Hoover he's a dirty old man with a
foul mouth a fondness for drug use and
an incredibly grumpy disposition the
wall our kin owns plenty of laughs of
colorful language
he also tugs on the old heartstrings and
scenes like the one where he tells his
tearful granddaughter that she'll never
be a loser so long as she tries to
accomplish her dreams you know what a
loser is a real loser is somebody that's
so afraid of now winning they don't even
try even though he's only in the film
for a scant 14 minutes he proved he was
definitely a winner when he snagged not
Oscar 1976 was an incredible year for
film and an even better one for
supporting actors Network marathon man
and rocky or featured powerful
supporting actor performances but when
the votes are all tallied up the little
gold statuette actually went to Jason
Robards for his commanding turn and all
the presidents man compared to his
competitors robots
performance as Washington Post editor
Ben Bradlee is incredibly understated
he's a prickly perfectionist and editor
who drives his reports as hard and
callous ietters their work but the man's
heart is in the right place sure he's
brash but he just wants a solid story
reporting that'll withstand the scrutiny
of everybody from Joe Schmo to the
President of the United States I can't
do the reporting for my reporters which
means I have to trust them and I hate
trusting anybody Robards has only
onscreen for about 14 minutes
but that was more than enough to impress
the Academy they say good things come to
those who wait and that's especially
true for Jack Palance the Hollywood
veteran was nominated for Best
Supporting Actor in 1952 for his
performance with a murderous husband and
sudden fear
sadly Palin's didn't win that year but
he got a second chance in 1953 earning
another nomination for his work as a
black cloud gunslinger in Shayne but
once again Palin's was robbed for Oscar
glory and he would have to wait nearly
40 more years before getting that gold
Palin's would finally get his Jew thanks
to his performance and city slickers a
1991 comedy that follows three city
dwellers who spend the vacation at a
dude ranch during their quest to become
Cowboys they meet a grizzled old Ranch
Hand by the name of curly Washburn
[Music]
that is the toughest man I've ever seen
in my life parlance is only onscreen for
around 12 minutes but his toughest nails
performance would nap him the best
Supporting Actor Oscar
it's Manos Youth apology judi dench is
perhaps the most British woman who's
ever lived
everything about sir just radiates
nobility so it's no wonder that Dench
won an Oscar for a performance as Queen
Elizabeth the first in Shakespeare in
Love even though she's only on screen
for three scenes it's a role she was
born to play whenever she stands every
knee bowels
she's commanding and demanding her
humerus biting and her words cut to the
bone what you love so much your majesty
speak up though I know who I am
but beneath that powdered powerful
exterior there's a woman with a love for
theatre and a sympathy for our
star-crossed lovers William Shakespeare
and viola ultimately hilarious and
powerful attention only appears in only
eight minutes of the film but she owns
all of them a complicated royal and a
deus ex machina rolled into one
dentures Queen Elizabeth is worthy of
both Allegiance and the wards I thought
you were here because you had none
in 1976 director Sidney Lumet created
one of the darkest most brilliant
satires ever put the film Network the
film holds up with incredible
performances but Beatrice Strait made
Academy Award history by winning Best
Supporting Actress with just 5 minutes
of screen time straight plays Louise the
jilted wife of a TV executive when her
husband confesses to having an affair
with a younger woman
Louise gives a hell and brimstone sermon
that no preacher will ever match both
embarrassed and filled with righteous
anger she lays into her husband hard
ripping him apart for his philandering
before breaking down and admitting how
much he's hurting her and as icing on
the acting cake as she ends a scene
actually feeling sorry for her husband
knowing that his new affair will just
leave him feeling a lot of grief all in
all straight only shows up in network
for 5 minutes and 40 seconds to this day
no one has beaten straights incredible
record and chances are good that she'll
hold onto the honor for a long long time
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite stuff are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]